we had chris harrison erotica
there's a lot of sex in it victoria
shaking up the plot icah we were worried
for you
and sarah not giving it a shot ika
you know i decided i'm going to leave
this is your the bachelor season 25
episode 3 recap grab your glasses
it's time for roses and rosie
hi everybody it's me lauren zema
and i don't know how to feel have i been
emotionally manipulated why didn't i
know my boyfriend had written an erotic
novel
sit back and awkwardly enjoy all of it
oh everyone so many questions and
so many feelings and such divisive
content on this episode of the bachelor
what did you think
we have so much to get into whose side
are you on in the sarah thing
has your front runner changed how am i
supposed to sit in this dress
that's more of my personal problem but i
do want you guys to tell me
i like this dress a lot i do it's the
adult american girl aesthetic that i so
always ascribe to but i don't know how
to sit in it like i'm like do i do the
princess diaries
ankle cross is it a full leg cross
princesses never cross their legs in
public
do i just give up let me know
in the comments below and it's also i
don't know why it's giving me sound of
music vibes maybe it's because it kind
of looks like
her i can wear this as a nun it's
approved dresses and
it looks put together the way that they
made the clothes for the kids out of the
curtains
i made them from the drapes that used to
hang in my bedroom do you guys know what
i'm talking about
so we've got a lot to discuss we are
emotionally unstable in the best
possible way we're like it must be
serious let's get to it
i'm blacking out like i can't see we
picked up
right where we left off and by that i
mean we picked sarah up
off the floor and by we i mean matt
specifically
was the one who did that but the
perception of sarah would decline
she is getting exactly what she wants
and we're gonna talk about it all
now sarah did apologize multiple times
for kind of fainting at the rose
ceremony i'm so sorry you guys
but a woman who doesn't seem into
apologies victoria
says this is not the sarah show
this is the bachelor it's not the sarah
show
kayla matt is giving out multiple roses
and victoria who we know loves her
vocabulary is saying
multiple words uh is she doing some kind
of word association game
marilyn manipulative toxicity
jesters questionable bizarre confusing
wine queens victoria
positivity realness
matt's heart how do you solve a problem
like victoria
how do you solve a problem like maria
well apparently this problem is not
going to get solved because
matt gives victoria the final rose
victoria matt nonsensical
invalid insane
victoria will you accept this rose yes
how incensed were you over that
let me know in the comments below i'll
admit i want victoria to stay on the
show because she is bringing the drama
i just can't believe marilyn was sent
home for doing
literally nothing oh and victoria
and her words are back again she is
gonna make a toast cheers to
continuing the journey and being
vulnerable even when it's really tough
and our villain is choosing a new target
sarah marilyn's gone and now sarah
needs to go and also and i quote all the
fake [ __ ]
seriously like all the fake [ __ ] you
can all
go home go home go home go home go home
get out and we start the group date with
words
some special words maybe it was time to
shake things up a bit
yes the women walk into a voice telling
them this
sexy tale of a woman grabbing a man's
buttocks with one hand she cupped his
buttocks
and him putting his lips on her neck his
lips moved to her ears her neck
she panted and their hips are against
each other
raising her hips to meet his they would
not like that
at the nunnery church i don't
know when we enter the abbey our worldly
clothes are given to the poor
a familiar face is reading those sultry
words
ashley hi allow me to introduce ashley i
and then and then and
then we learned the words were written
by a familiar author but it's passionate
it's erotic and to be really frank
there's a lot of sex in it
that was chris harrison's book
[Music]
there's a very important writer and his
name
is chris harrison
yes you guys you guys
you guys i'm just gonna admit it i've
never read his book so i didn't know
that my own boyfriend had written this
softcore erotica and to be really frank
there's a lot of sex in it my pearls
i don't have any yeah so that's on me
and i think i gotta read the book
[Music]
oh oh
oh okay yeah briefing's got nothing on
me
and the women have to write their own
love scenes
so today you're going to be writing your
own love story with matt
now the women who are not technically on
the group date are the audience
and one of those women is sarah she has
an interesting
response to all of this and this is kind
of uh literally the beginning of the end
isn't it sarah says that listening to
these love scenes is going to be
and i quote brutal this is going to be
so brutal what did you think of that i
disagreed i thought
liz gonna be hilarious yeah hilarious
sexy
some combination of the two you guys get
to just sit back and awkwardly
enjoy all of it matt did pretty well i
thought he he appeared to have some kind
of
sexy boss lady fantasy going i heard
talk of a suit
he kissed the skin between her suit
and her hairline what did you think let
me know in the comments below going
through all of the pulitzer prize
winning works quickly
uh serena rhymed so that was fun all the
things in the past
that was evidently lacking i know my
man's matt james is packing
rachel said groin which was a weird
choice and my
groin immediately cluttered with desire
and
then things got dirty i mean this is
network television and we had to censor
some people out
don't drink for every bee she
immediately
and press firmly against her until she
was
before he set her down
all the way to us
[Music]
just coming up for some air so but we're
having fun and our reactions to it all
are part of the fun so you know what
don't drink for every chris harrison
reaction shot
[Music]
i don't know why he's clutching the
pearls he doesn't have you
started this with your fan fiction
erotica
mommy porn moment is soft core what the
heck
i did we have to talk
we're gonna we're gonna talk about this
i'm not not angry about it i just
have a lot of questions
and then and then and then
katie's gotta go and you know
if you remember how could you forget
katie brought a vibrator
on night one and i mean it's a party
like
we got the glow stick going so the bar
is high here matt picked up katie
eager to kiss her and it was so deeply
censored
i don't know what katie's story was i
lost the narrative
i didn't catch any of the characters all
the way to his
i'm unclear on the plot beginning to end
oh my god yes
i'll have what she's having oh but
victoria's still gotta go
these girls are a little too vanilla so
what is our queen going to do
she's gonna set her story in a palace
yes she was the queen matt was the king
the king and queen were celebrating
their royal engagement
we were all choking on our drinks
[Applause]
and you guys i loved it the other women
said it was amazing
i think victoria's story was amazing
they were laughing applauding it ended
with
a yes queen and they came together and
he screamed
yes queen is this unexpected softcore
erotica dates a redemption arc for
victoria
it gets better did you start to like
victoria
let me know in the comments below what i
did appreciate was that she seemed to
just have a sense of humor about the
whole thing but i loved the way the
women were supporting each other
though there was one who was not
don't drink for every face sarah made
yes she said that the other women's
fiction felt like
and i quote a knife through her heart
it just felt like a knife like through
my heart
sarah people were saying groin maybe a
knife to the groin
i was like feeling on cloud nine like so
amazing on our one-on-one date
sarah said that because she'd had such a
great one-on-one date with matt
that all of this was just so painful i
just didn't
know it was gonna be this hard what did
you think of that response
let me know in the comments below when
the women go back to their
living quarters she can't even be around
them i think she kind of just doesn't
want to
hear it like she's not interested yeah
though those on the group date
are still on it and apparently she can
get into that
sarah crashes the group date that she's
not on
can i steal you for a second and the
women are upset victoria says
i would interrupt on my own group date
but not on someone else's yeah like i'll
interrupt my own group date but i would
never step outside on another group date
am i agreeing with victoria
what's the story let me know in the
comments below um
but katie is gonna go and get her time
back because she was interrupted by
sarah
i don't know are you guys done can i
have my time back
and then sarah comes and makes a group
apology
and it did not go great um how do you
guys think she could have done or
handled this better tell me
she says i stole the time and i'm sorry
i know this is
your group date like your time so i'm
just still not for a couple moments
and they're like but you did it but you
did it after the fact
and she says well i wanted you to hear
it from me i just want to let you guys
know why i'm here
and they're like but we're not hearing
anything from you what happened and
i'm sorry you didn't let us know why
that's why you're here now i did not
think that sarah had to share
everything with the women but i also
didn't truly understand why it was so
urgent for her to talk to matt
i agreed with them she'd already had a
one-on-one date and babe
it could wait i don't want anyone to
feel ganged up on
somebody's gotta solve this and the
person
extending the olive branch is victoria
are you okay no that was really intense
she follows her out
into the night and while her tone was a
little intense
her words were nice i'm sorry to hurt
you guys i mean it was a personal
conversation and that's fine but it was
a personal conversation on our time
look at the end of the day there are two
things to consider in any conversation
right
your words and your delivery and i
thought
sarah's delivery was kind but her
actions and words could have been better
i thought katie and victoria's delivery
was a little intense
like are you having insecurities like as
a short answer
but i didn't think they were wrong what
did you think
use the best internet tone you can and
let me know in the comments below
but rachel and her groin get the group
rose uh
rachel will you accept this rose
of course something and the other women
are upset because they didn't just
not get the rose they didn't get any
time
he hasn't talked to me yet i'm just
i'm so angry i'm so upset and as anna
says
time is money time is a commodity here
and right now
sarah is like a billionaire everyone is
breaking down
serena c is like sarah needs to be a
grown woman she needs to get her
together at the end of the day it's like
you're a grown-ass woman and you should
be strong enough to hold out those
feelings until it's your time
and she is saying this while breaking
down and saying she can't handle this
anymore i'm so sick of feeling
frustrated
we're doing a lot of censoring but it
feels right for this episode
oh but we've calmed down a little bit
and now serena p
is going to go on her one-on-one i am
beyond excited to get to spend the whole
day with him doing
whatever the heck we're gonna be doing
and i thought she was looking so cute in
her little turtleneck and coat
we're getting a little lighter we're
getting a little brighter in our energy
this show is the gift that keeps on
giving oh and then we are getting dark
again
um sarah isn't here she's not she's here
no she's she hasn't haven't seen her
nobody's seen her
she's the only one who isn't here
sora is sarah she's laying in bed and
when matt comes to pick up serena
he goes to check on sarah and he says
he's gonna be
a just five minutes will you give me
like five minutes
but he's not yes while matt is gone
comforting sarah
don't drink for every time someone says
they want her to go home
somebody wants to go let them go maybe
she's packing her bags and saying bye to
him now
let us pray sometimes you just let a
[ __ ] go my best advice to sarah would
be
you should pack your bags and go home
the vibe was getting
a little gang up on e to me which i
didn't like
but we've gotta get out of bed and clear
our heads matt and serena are on horses
cue obligatory bridgerton clip
you look good in a horse suits you they
are on horses roaming through the nature
the hills are alive
with the sound of matt james
you look so tiny on that horse serena
is talking about horses
horse is apparently a really good judge
of character i love it so much
what did you think of matt and serena's
connection i thought that she was fun
and a great conversationalist i mean
she's got horse facts
like they can sense fear and stuff in
people and speaking of lessons
talking about learning it's time to get
educated
serena is teaching matt how to make a
charcuterie
i like a good brie cheese with some jam
are you can you
where's your pen and paper you should be
writing this down
[Music]
usually i'll throw some dark chocolate
on here
brie cheese on crackers and meats on a
wood board
goat cheese and almonds all things that
i adore
salami and honey what else did you bring
these are a few of my favorite things
what a dream oh everybody it is just
wonderful to see two people on a date
really talking about the important
topics
we have our meats and cheese selections
forget your childhood
your passions your future talk about the
cheese
i like a good brie cheese with some jam
prosciutto and fig jam
spread it on your knives these are the
things that make me
feel alive
and then and then
then just as this show is the gift that
keeps on giving it is sometimes the gift
that taketh away
matt james says he doesn't drink
wine well i'm not a big wine drinker
okay okay
i'm not a big wine drinker okay
i'm not a big wine drinker okay okay
why chardonnay
cabernet rose please bring
me back to life you're my favorite
things yeah i'm good i'm good
they have a good conversation and i did
love serena talking about wanting to
experience this
non-linear life not what her parents had
necessarily
set out for her school job career
marriage kids it's all been very linear
and matt explaining that
he wants to have a partner my mom i've
seen what it's like for her
to grow older and not be in a
relationship and i say
wine cheers to that matt
they still love me still a good guy
teach their own honestly if you don't
like wine that's fine bring some tequila
bring some sparkling apple juice i don't
care let's just have a good time
and i did write down justice for matt's
open
eye kisses because serena kisses him
with her eyes open
and now granted it was because a donkey
appeared
donkey what was going on here
were the producers behind the cameras
going okay release the donkeys
hey buddy you're really killing the moon
are alive literally with the donkeys
okay oh and then this show really is
that yet that keeps on giving because
we get another hot tub
and another fire pit oh i told you guys
last week i just love the outdoor hot
tub moments
they added in a fire pit and this time
they upped the ante even more
yes they gave us the wood-burning hot
tub
near a fire pit it did seem unsafe i was
a little concerned
but you know what pop the champagne heat
things up
no but from the tops of the hills to the
bottoms of the valleys we've got to do
our 72nd
sarah check-in of the episode we are
still
missing a good friend sarah
i'm not missing her but she finally
leaves her bed to come down for the date
card
yeah she comes in and it was so awkward
squeeze it how are you she's like oh
hi can i come in here can i sit here
yeah you know can you just can you just
you just scooch a little bit thank you
yeah if you could can i just get in here
can i
if you guys can scooch down good to see
you how are you hi yes hi
squeezing i've been in my room in my bed
yeah okay just snapping
singing about me and matt okay victoria
is saying
the wildest crap i think if you guys
have had the chance to get to know me
over the past
time hopefully you guys know my heart
and see my heart
and i have had great conversations and
connections with you ladies and
you know i know who is she talking to
here they're saying we don't want to
make amends with you
why do you think that we want to make
amends with you we don't want to be
friends with you
i do not accept your apology even if you
say it 20 more times
your living situation here is going to
be horrible
i hope that your connection with matt is
very strong right now because the rest
of
your living situation here is going to
be horrible
it was just mean yeah so sarah's like i
do remy fossola don't want to be here
anymore
it's just so it's really difficult for
me and how did you all feel about this
conversation i was not okay with many of
the comments
but i will say one that stuck out to me
was anna's she was kind of calling sarah
out and saying
look you're saying this is a difficult
situation for you but
it's tough for all of us if i talked to
him every time i felt insecure
no one would be having time right now
it's really difficult for me and i think
you haven't had it difficult
you've had a one-on-one you had extra
time with him here's the thing
while your problems and feelings
are valid you're not the only one having
problems and feelings
so sarah says she's gonna get in a car
and go and bernie made up my mind
you know i decided i'm going to leave
katie reached out to her
went and had a human conversation and
cheers to that
so much of the time i think that the
best communication and growth happens in
just person-to-person interactions
and sarah explains this by saying yes
part of this is issues happening in the
house
it's been a combination of things but
part of it is
my dad don't i haven't really opened up
to you about
the situation with my dad but he has a
terminal illness
and like it's not like
years or months it's like maybe like
weeks so babe i'm saying
go home ultimately how did you all feel
about sarah let me know in the comments
below
i truly wish her the best i hope that
she was able to go home and spend some
time with her family
and figure things out and look if you
didn't think you could handle being here
on the show
then great go absolutely it's okay
i'm ready to talk to matt we've had
enough drama this week
we all deserve a break and then we get
the promo
are five new girls we're getting
five new women
who the are these random ass hoes do
remy fosso la ti
whoa you have 30 women now
35 women what are you going to do matt
yes you guys the show is taking a little
bit of a bachelor in paradise
turn and we are getting five new
women entering the house for matt to
date
what will they think of next is the gift
that keeps on giving
giving us new women so many women
how do you feel about this and the
episode let me know in the comments
below of course i wanted to hear
everything from you guys i love you so
much
thank you for watching if you want to
connect with me more you can find me on
instagram
twitter and tick tock at laurenzema and
if you want a personal message from me i
am on cameo do remy falsolla
[Music]
and there's only one way to end this one
so long
farewell avida
and yeah and yeah and yeah and yeah
i leave and heave a sigh and say goodbye
good bye
you